- We all know I'm not nice.
(Francesca laughing)
We all know you're not nice either.
- I am nice!
- You're like, I'm nice,
I'm the friendly one.
(hinges squeaking)
(drum rolling)
- Today we have four self-identified garbage people,
and we're putting them to the test
to find out how garbage they really are.
Let's meet our contestants.
- [Alp] Hi my name is Alp and I love flavored rum.
- [Francesca] I'm Francesca and I love yelling in public.
- [Aaron] I'm Aaron and I drink wine like it's water.
- [Sarah] Hi, my name's Sarah and I ate Doritos for dinner.
(cheesy gameshow music)
(bell ringing)
- [Host] To end a hug you usually:
A: Wait for the other person to move.
B: Tap their shoulder twice.
C: I don't hug.
- Yeah, probably A, I'm a hugger.
- When I get a little tipsy I hug my friends,
and everybody loves it
and they always make a big deal about it,
but then, like the next day I'm like
^Oh, please don't, don't hug me.
- I do the two cheek kisses thing if you're into that.
- Ooh, very French.
- Very Turkish.
- Garbage.
(speaking in foreign language)
(Sarah laughing)
- I don't want to hug other people.
(bell rings)
- [Host] Have you ever forgotten you're parent's birthday?
A: Yes, and I felt so bad.
B: No.
C: Yes, and it will probably happen again.
- [Alp] C.
- We're not that bad.
- I love you mom.
- I've amost forgotten my parent's birthday,
but TBH, I don't think I ever have.
- We love you.
Just because we don't remember your birthday
doesn't mean we don't love you.
(bell rings)
- You're insanely hungry.
The only thing left in the fridge
is your roommate's lasagna.
Do you:
A: Leave it untouched.
B: Cut off a tiny piece.
or C: Demolish it?
- Oh my gah! (laughing)
Is it this specific lasagna,
because if it is then, that shit's mine.
^- B, definitely B.
- Yeah, definitely.
It's already cut into.
- Yeah, it's gonna be easy to do a secret slice.
^- You gotta be a self advocate.
You know, if you need that food, take that food.
^- I'm gonna be sneaky about it.
I'm gonna take just a little bit so that
they don't notice it but enough where I'm satisfied.
- It was gonna go in the trash anyway.
You're doing them a favor.
(bell rings)
- When you say, "I'll be right there!"
you really mean:
A: I'm still in bed.
B: I'm about 15 minutes away.
C: I'm not coming.
- [Alp] It's like, it's A or B, I've done both.
^- I'm always late,
but I don't want my friends to be mad at me,
so I act like I'm on time.
^- I'm perpetually late.
I try to blame it on things.
I'm like, "Oh, it's 'cause I'm gay."
I should be on time for things, I'm just not.
- I don't wanna get there and have you be later than me.
- This is bad garbage.
There's a good garbage.
(bell rings)
- [Host] You now must choose between
your favorite healthy snack
and your favorite unhealthy snack.
- No!
This is really hard.
- Not even a question.
Are you kidding me?
- No.
- This.
^- The Milanos obviously.
- I would probably go with this right now,
but not because I'm a paragon of health.
- You know honestly (bleeping) this test.
I'm eating all this food.
Sorry, Francesca.
- No. (laughing)
- I would consider my eating habits to be fully trash.
- Mmhmm.
- I've been waiting for the day my metabolism
is openly gonna revolt.
- I'm so happy.
- You know trash people need their vitamins too
- These are, like, popcorn.
It's from, like, corn kernels, and corn is a vegetable so,
yeah, works for me.
- These trash humans have now taken the test.
Now I will calculate the results.
^(speaking in foreign language)
^- That shit's mine.
^- I don't wanna hug other people.
^- You're doing them a favor.
- The results are in.
Not all garbage is created equal,
but you're all beautiful trash humans in my eyes.
Congratulations everyone, you all win.
- No! (laughing)
- This feels correct.
- See mom, I won something.
- If you're garbage be proud of yourself that's who you are.
- I'm sorry but I don't plan on changing.
- You're supposed to act how you know you are on the inside
and one day people will recognize you for what that is.
- Well, that's all folks.
We know we're not alone.
Let us know how trashed you are in the comments below.
(funky rock music)
(hinge squeaks)